Hi, I'm Henry. Because MCP is such a new
space, uh instead of going into
technical details like most AI engineer
videos that you're probably seeing, uh
today I'll be doing a highle overview
and a rant about all the problems within
the MCP space and ecosystem. A quick
introduction about myself. Um so I'm
Henry. I'm the founder and CEO of
Smithery. Uh I'm also a member of the
MCP sir committee. Before Smidy, um I
co-founder Jenny AI. Um let me tell you
a little bit about the origin story for
Smidy. Um this is around November last
year 2024. Uh I went down this rabbit
hole trying to figure out uh trying to
tackle the ARC AGI challenge. And if you
haven't heard of the ARC AGI challenge,
it's an IQ test made for LLMs. And in
this challenge, um you're given two or
three different examples of a pattern.
And you want your LM to predict the
missing last pattern here. And turns out
that this challenge is very easy for
humans to do. Humans get about uh 80%
accuracy on this challenge, but it's
pretty hard for LM to do. And LMS could
not crack it for many many years. So I I
kind of focused on tackling the
challenge. Uh but very quickly, uh
OpenAI decided to release 03. and Ozu
completely dominated the ARC AGI1
challenge and basically got human level
performance. It scored very well on math
benchmarks as well. So, we're basically
done, right? AGI achieved. Um,
autonomous agents are going to be
solving all our problems now. But fast
forward to
2025 and I'm wondering where are all the
autonomous agents? Why are they not
solving all the tasks that we don't want
to be doing? So, what we're seeing here
is sort of Claude's paradox. uh we have
all these frontier labs creating uh all
this intelligence but all this
intelligence is stuck in a box and in
order to make AI agents practically
useful we have to start thinking about
context and capability what are the
inputs and outputs uh to our models
everyone from startups to major labs
recognize this problem and so in
November 2024 anthropic released the
model context protocol uh it's an open
standard to help LMS connect to
different services uh with a promise of
standardizing uh this end times end
problem. So when I saw MCPS uh in around
this time last year, I was pretty
excited about it. Um there was a small
but vibrant developer community. So
models are getting smarter and MCPs are
standardizing the way models talk to
services. So are we finally done? Well,
not quite. With MCP and a new ecosystem
of services trying to target AI agents,
we have a bunch of new problems showing
up. So first I want to go through the
list of user problems that we have. So
the first one is fragmentation. There
are more and more MCP servers being
deployed every single day and it's
becoming hard to find high quality ones.
The MCP committee is currently working
on a better solution for this by
creating an official registry thanks to
test and the pulse MCP team. Simply
having a registry doesn't solve the
problem. For example, how do we assign
reputation to highquality MCPS is still
an open question.
Another problem that MCP users face is
high friction install. If you go to any
MCP's GitHub repository, you you'll
probably see this five-step installation
process, which makes it very difficult
to install. And in addition to that,
once you have your MCP installed, you
might just have installed an insecure
unsecure MCP. Finally, it's unclear how
we're going to create this new economy
of AI native services. We don't have a
plan on how to handle agentic payments.
Open questions in this area include, how
do I get agents to pay on my behalf? And
how do I avoid subscribing to 100
different services uh each charging $10
a month? Next, let's look at the
developer side problems. So, if you're
building an MCP, you probably face
hosting problems. Thanks to the Streambo
HTTP transport is now much easier for
developers to find platforms to host on.
But hosting is still a challenge. Uh
developers will have to deal with staple
sessions, resumability, and other
issues.
The developer tooling is also uh quite
lacking in the MCP space. We have a
basic MCP inspector provided by the
official MCP repository which allows you
to test out different tools uh check out
your prompts but there are still open
questions that developers are asking us.
For example, how do I design the best
MCPS? How do I know if my tool is going
to be called? How do I create the best
agent
experience? Next, we also have
distribution as a problem. If you're a
developer, you create an MCP. How does
your MCP get discovered? Observability
is also an issue. If you deploy your MCP
and people are using it, how do you
improve this MCP once it's
launched? And lastly, how do you make
money out of your MCPs? So, in summary,
the MCP ecosystem is very exciting, but
it has a bunch of different problems. On
the left side, we have all the problems
faced by MCB users. On the right side,
we have problems faced by all the MCB
developers. That's why we're building
Smidy. I started Smidy in around
December 2024 to tackle these
challenges. Smittery is aiming to become
the AI gateway to grow and orchestrate
this new era of AI native services for
AI agents. So far, we've only scratched
the surface of the problems I've
described uh previously. But we built
this little demo to showcase what you
can build when some of these problems
are solved. So here what you're seeing
is uh the spittery playground. The main
goal of the playgrounds for us is to
demonstrate what an AI agent can do when
it has access to thousands of curated
MCPs. So let's start with a prompt. Find
the most pressing issue on my GitHub
repository called
smidy- CLI and create a new ticket on
linear. Okay. So let's submit this
prompt. You'll see the agent first start
thinking about the issue. It does. It
then calls this search servers function
which uh looks up for all the servers
within SPI3. It connects to the best
server. It also connects to
linear. It's able to go on uh GitHub
using the GitHub MCP to find uh
different
bugs. It's trying to find the most high
priority item.
So I found a team and now it's creating
uh a ticket on
linear. Great. So it looks like our
agent has successfully uh went on GitHub
looked for the most pressing issue uh on
my GitHub issues and created a linear
ticket. So let's take a look at this
ticket. Nice. Okay. So it has a lot of
details. It has even a link to the
original issue. Um yeah, so we have sort
of an endto-end uh task uh being solved
by an AI agent connected to two
different MCPs. So obviously, you know,
this demo only scratched the surface,
but you can imagine what we can do when
more and more servers get deployed on
Spitter. So this graph kind of shows you
the number of servers being deployed uh
over the last couple months and the
number of tool calls we've been getting.
With all this developer enthusiasm, I'm
confident that we can solve all the
problems that I mentioned in this talk
today. It's clear to me that the future
of the internet will be dominated by
tool calls rather than
clicks. And in this new world, it's
going to be the agent experience that
matters more than the user experience.
And this agent experience is not going
to be built by just me or a few
companies. It's going to be built by all
of you. Thank you.